protestas por la violencia policial un
grupo de 200 personas salió a la plaza
de la republica en parís para
manifestarse contra el asesinato de una
mujer a manos de la policía la semana
pasada
nosotros estamos aquí porque una mujer
joven que era pasajera en un coche la
policía ha dicho que el coche no quiso
pararse en un control y por lo tanto han
disparado varios policías eran tres y la
mujer ha muerto el conductor quién es un
delincuente reincidente resultó herido
en el tórax él fue imputado por
tentativa de homicidio de los policías
se encuentra detenido los agentes tras
ser interrogados fueron dejados en
libertad sin cargos el colectivo de
familiares de los que han muerto o han
sido heridos en acciones de la policía
fue uno de los organizadores de la
marcha exigen la derogación de un
artículo de la ley de 2017 sobre la
seguridad interior este artículo permite
a los policías usar sus armas en caso de
absoluta necesidad cuando está en
peligro su integridad física o la de
otras personas los agentes quienes han
sido criticados por tener un
entrenamiento deficiente se defienden ya
para 12 para uruguay no es en absoluto
el derecho a matar al contrario tenemos
un montón de limitaciones al final al
utilizar el arma no estamos en absoluto
en el derecho a matar ahmed un final del
cáncer de la oms hemos oído decir que es
una licencia para matar
no es así
youtube youtube las críticas y la
presión por parte de la sociedad civil
aumentan tras presentarse más casos
donde la policía se ha visto envuelta en
homicidios de civiles